happy Mother's Day to every type of
mother every mother a lot of you
listening right now
and you're a mother you got something
you know
there's no other that's how I mean
that's God's peephole baby
that's how God looks out into the world
through a mother you are the liaison
you're the on-ramp between the Lord and
Earth you got that on-ramp you got that
thorough fire you got that yum tunnel on
you that's how God serves them that's
how he serves the world of a woman's
body a woman's
however they say it out there in some of
these other continents the vain yeah
that's how the you know
that's how the the the the that that's
how the Lord sir you know
that's how he just
puts people on earth
that's God's last hand that's his last
that's his that's how he reaches out
into the world
through a woman through a mother
that's really fascinating
if I told you there was a portal right
say I come up to you
you're sitting somewhere you're having a
sandwich or something you're having a
little
cut of meat cut up uh
cheese
you know you're having a cut of meat cut
of cheese two breads
you know what it is a sandwich
say you're having that you're sitting on
a little river bank or something I come
up to you
I say buddy
um
I'm gonna tell you where there's a
portal
where you can go into another Realm
you'd be you'd be there in a heartbeat
well that's what that's what a mother
there mother that's the only way
the only way
to get from the brain of the of God
of the of the powers that be
of Mother Nature and father time the
only portal
is through a dang
woman a mother
or this as some people call her I
don't you know I don't say that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one